suivez moi j'ai quelque chose à vous
montrer quelque chose d'unique le monde
est constitué d'histoire et toutes ces
histoires sont rassemblés dans le livre
de la vie
mais la plus extraordinaire d'entre
elles débutent le jour des morts le jour
où les esprits passe d'un monde à
l'autre est un peu tard
regarde moi ça 2 amiens c'est pas un
amoureux de la mer vous vous conduisez
tous les deux comme des crétins moi
aussi aimerait elle a l'air très commode
il dit mais si on se faisait un petit
paru
ah je parie que marina et ouvrages aux
atouts très bien en vertu d'une règle
d'antan le pari est lancé à naulleau je
vais trop vite mon vieil ami je ne serai
pas le héros de la ville maria j'te jure
du fond du coeur que jamais je ne
cesserai d'aimer
certes mais où suis-je bienvenue au pays
des âmes chéri un conseil n'essaie pas
de tout faire d'un seul coup
c'est fabuleux mega fiesta 7 jours sur 7
et 24 heures sur 24
madame je vous en prie aidez moi à
retrouver l'amour de ma vie si tu
réussis ces épreuves alors tu pourra
revoir maría
hu à mourir ça donnait mon dos et
surtout sur la troupe
la légende de manolo je sais exactement
ce qu'il vous jouez au j'ai trop besoin
de toi
waouh c'est clair que là et les
scotchaient le 22 octobre au cinéma